welcome mere humans to my show I have
risen from the dead to be your host
Gordon gruesome you're in store for six
of the most wretched formulas for a meal
set your mother's cooking those with
squeamish stomachs should leave now
because we are the wok
[Music]
this episode of The Walking Dead is
brought to you by : our productions put
in the craft and craft services on this
episode of The Walking Dead will be
eating baby brain sees these world and :
our productions are not responsible if
you die from eating this recipe
responsible what happens ah okay anyways
you'll need these items foil sauces
plants a sharp knife pork wonton
wrappers and of course go walking dead
also some corn starch but first finely
chop the vegetables
[Music]
now put in the bowl and refrigerate I
want to see if there's any room in here
now you're gonna need some of these
things and a shot of corn starch with a
cup of water and you'll need this this
is what we use to tell the baby throw
the other stuff in the garbage and put
the baby's head in the mix all right
take this and smash until well blended
whoa whoa Cory good are you crazy
Child Protective Services is right
outside the building you're gonna get a
shutdown it's just a human baby anyways
you'll make little eyeballs out of the
brain matter
brains need oxygen to survive so make a
super tight seal I'll set those aside
and as promised by the title of this
thing you're watching then you put the
wontons in the wok get those suckers in
there nice and airtight baby brain once
you've done that at two-and-a-half shots
of water now set the heat to medium
inferno because things are about to get
steamy
[Music]
now let's remove these babies from the
walk all right get it in there cover
with sauce oh now it's ready to serve to
the [ __ ] let's give them a truck
this is Child Protective Services put
your hands where I can see them hey are
you doing thanks for watching the first
episode of The Walking Dead don't forget
to subscribe and if you have a tree you
want us to conjure up click here also
try this in your own kitchen at your own
home thanks for watching and we'll see
you next time
you